jose usa 0.4 32 kilogramos de queso para
preparar macarrones con queso o también
le podemos decir a esto 432 milésimas de
kilogramo de queso para preparar
macarrones con queso redondea la
cantidad de queso a la décima más
cercana la cantidad de queso es 0.4 32
kilogramos y nos piden redondear la
cantidad a la décima más cercana
recordemos los lugares de valor aquí van
las décimas aquí van las centésimas
estas son heces y significan décimas
centésimas y milésimas
nos piden redondear a la décima más
cercana y para hacerlo nos fijamos en el
número que se encuentra a la derecha de
este lugar si este número es menor que 5
lo vamos a redondear hacia abajo y si es
mayor que 5 lo vamos a redondear hacia
arriba pero como este 3 es menor que 5
vamos a redondear hacia abajo y nos van
a quedar justamente 4 décimas
así que redondeamos hacia abajo y nos
queda 0 punto
400 cómo podemos escribirlo como 0.4 o
también decir que son cuatro décimas
hagamos otro problema el caracol mascota
de elisa recorre 2.197 metros en un día
redondea la distancia a la centésima más
cercana pausa en el vídeo y traten de
redondear esta cantidad a la centésima
más cercana
tenemos 2.197 este es el lugar de las
centésimas y como nos piden redondear a
la centésima más cercana
vemos el número que está un lugar a la
derecha de esta posición si el número
que está a la derecha de esta posición
es mayor o igual que 5 lo vamos a
redondear hacia arriba y 7 es más grande
que 5 por lo que vamos a redondear esto
hacia arriba esto es interesante ya que
si redondeamos un 9 hacia arriba
tendremos un 10 pero no podemos poner
todo un 10 aquí una forma de pensar en
esto es imaginar que tenemos un 19 aquí
y entonces sí podemos redondear lo de 19
avn
y otra forma de verlo es que si
redondeamos el 9 hacia arriba vamos a
tener un 10 que agregamos al número que
se encuentra al lado izquierdo así que
nos queda 2 puntos y podemos ver esto
como 19 centésimas y 7 milésimas y si lo
redondeamos nos va a quedar 20
centésimas esto lo podríamos escribir
como 2.2 pero para que quede claro que
redondeamos a la centésima más cercana
ponemos 2.20 aquí y más adelante podría
importar que mostremos hasta donde
estamos redondeando resolvamos otro
ejemplo carolina pasa a 6.75 horas al
día en la escuela redondea la cantidad
de tiempo a la hora más cercana así que
nos dicen que son 6.75 y los invito a
qué pausa en el vídeo y traten de
resolver esto como el que vamos a
redondear esto a la hora más cercana
esto puede ser algo confuso ya que no
nos están pidiendo que redondeamos a la
décima o a la centésima más cercana sino
a la hora más cercana pero en este caso
las horas se encuentran en el lugar de
las unidades
es decir que redondeamos a la hora más
cercana es lo mismo que decir redondea a
la unidad más cercana así que vemos el
lugar que se encuentra a la derecha de
esta posición y vemos si es mayor o
igual que 5 de ser así vamos a redondear
arriba y en efecto 7 es mayor que 5 así
que vamos a redondear arriba a la
siguiente hora que es 7 así que son 7
horas si esto hubiera sido 6.4 9999 y
queremos redondear a la hora más cercana
vemos el valor que se encuentra un lugar
a la derecha de esta posición y no
importa que se encuentren todos estos
nueves acá simplemente notamos que el 4
es menor que 5 así que vamos a redondear
abajo en esta ocasión y la hora más
cercana que se encuentra por debajo de
6.4 9 9 9 9 y 6 pero en el problema
tenemos un 7 en el lugar de las décimas
que es mayor o igual a 5 así que vamos a
redondear arriba a la siguiente hora que
es 7 horas